OF U.S AD FORCESIN AFGHANI.WH AN
APL E WOULSEPTEMBER, AND WE ON T
TO MGER E ON
1st.AWDOWN ICURE ARDAY
TIESND T S O
SWIFTLY  MAIN E ME
.
HAVD OUR WITHAW
ONE, NO U.S. FCES OR A
FORC HE BEEN
CO
ERCOME WITH ANAS O R PERSONNEL.
RISKS
ANY DOUBATRFORMED THISK  HST OF
PROFESSIONM.EY DO. OF OUND
NG US AS WELL, AS EY CDE.
I WANT TO BES.ARN INGHANISTAN CL
ANN  -- EXCUSE , THUNDER WHICE A
D USN  AND DELIVER JUSTICE TO
EGRI
FGNI
BECOMING AFR D EDAIE TATES.
WECHE OBJECTIVES.
TH.
WE DID TLDD
RIGHT AND SIBILITY OEO
THEIFUND HOWNTUNHE COUNTRY.ERR
AND R --
300,000 CURRENT SERVIN MILITARYE
OUR AFGHAN
D ADVANCE WEAPONRY, ENT, OFANY .
GO CONTITOD
ANTHE THO MAINTAIN AIR
BUT, MOST CRITICALLY AS I MY
HANI AND
LEADERTHWA
IN OUREETINGI ALSOURED ANI THLE
ENDURE. TO CIIA
ASSISTANCE, INCLUDING SPEAKING
OUFOTS OF WOMED
OUR IC PRESE
AFGHANISTAN AND WE ARENANG W
L PARTNERSN ORDER
E TOTHE
INTEIORPORT, AND W
GOING TO ENGAG DETERMINEAT WILL
SLE VIOLENC ASKED SRY OF STATE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR AFGHAST
ONO E PARTIE
AFIS
NEGOTIATED SOLUTION.
CLEAR, TO BELE,  THEEG AESSENTI
WE'LRKH
SHP THEIR
E GOINFOAMS INCLUDINEXCUSE ME,GO
ORRECTLY, CAMILY SAFELY.
LSO WILLON MAKE
SURE WE TAKE O
S INCLUDING E BY
SIWEG TO ORS
HAG TO NEETH
Y VE NJO ALSO GOING TO BE VITA
HAVE BEEN VERY,
A
WE'VE ALREADATPROCEDUR
VISAS TO COMHEMIGRAN O THUNS.WAI
STATES.
UP TO NOW WEALEXERCISED TH.
N AIRCFTAL FLIGHTS ANDD THR HALR
AUTHORIZATION LEION SO WE CASTR
OFSE
AND THOSE WHHA UFOTHE OPERATIORC
OAFGHANEIEFORE
E OF OSEY CA
R
VIARE BEIND.
E S IDENTIFIED ITIES OUTSIDCONT
AOUNTRIES T AFGF THEY
OOSE -- THEY SO CHSE
D
WE'RE GOING TON
S FOR AFANN SI
WH
WE HAVE D AT TASK FORCE
E TO ISAR. A
THE U.S.ENISTAN JUDGED.E THE DEN
INI DEMEISAR
EYES AND BLY OE BATTLEFIELD
BUT R O ARGUED T STAIXT ONR,
THEMSONS O HISTORY.
IN NATO ALLINDRT WWOD
END OUCOMBAT
INMORE
E KEPT FIGHTING ANWE TAKING CASS
IN AND O 2 EXPHAS SHOWN USE CURR
CUITNFIRMS
BUT A RECIPE FORNGHERE TELY.
THR COUNTRY.THE AFGHANS TO MUT F
CTARGUMENT I W WITE AFGHAN AND
AFGHANISTAN INDEFINITELY.
FAHAES IN THIST , EYE E STATUS I
MINIMAL.
BU REALITY AND
E FACT AEA GROUND IN AFGHANISTA.
TH OF  FORCEIN D  REDUCED TO
A BARE IE LAST
ADMINISTRAONNTTHIBAN TMO A FORC
TALIBAD CEASED MAJ
THAT THENI WAS GOING
K --T
AGREEMENT DENI
STATES AND ALLIE
TH
WOULD HAVEIN
Q NOTN
OP.IN.S. CASUALTIES.ICANOMEN
THE MIDDF VIL WA
WE WOULDOF
TO SEND MOOPS BACKO N TO DR
MAINING PSCEENT WITHE,NGWINIE W
MI PARENTST IN AGO.U AN WEL ANDM
WOYOOUER?
DOART TRAINING AND
DSTHOUSA
OFN NATIONAL SECURITY D
DEFENSFORCES, 44ER
CRNG A W YEARSGOFERENTE.S NNEM
MEEE
Y T THREAT H
ME TAKE
D AFGHANISTAN.
WE ARE ADAPTI
REATS WHER
MAKE NMISTAKE, MILITARY
E DERSRE
PROTECT THE T ALLENGE EMERGING
COUNTERTERSM OVER THE PABILITY L
WE ANECURING
ET THE S NA AND OTHIONS
THAT IREO
DETEE AV DEFEA AMED THE  MAK
DEMIC  BL
THREAT.
NEED TO EIOCYBER
TOIGAL THREATS OOF EMERGINESD E
THE LO I THETT YEARS
NOT THE LAST WANT TONI
INCREDIBLE SACRIFICE ONHAE S.
N PEL OUR ALLIES ANDPARTNEAV O
S IN AFGHANISTAN.O HONOR TH
T THEYSHED A
THE GREAONAL ANSTFA
PURSUINGERRORIST THREA
STUNFORGIVING TERRPLANET
I WANT TTHRVICE D  TO E MISSIO T
YOU ANURAMS UR OWAR.
I WILL NER
GAVE THE LAST FUDE
E  BEEN IMMEASURABLYNDS SUSTAIN
THAVER TICAND BLESS U Y
PRU.
DENT, DO
YOU TRUST E N.
AFW EV?rteR.REN TAKEOVF
r:HY?E TH
TROOPS, HA 300,000
INOT INEVITABLE.
>> Reporter: PNTDOTHE TALIBAN,I?
>> QUEST
TALIBAN?S
NO, I D
RUS T
>>O, DUST TH
>> Repr: E FOR THE DETER WE LEAT
CO>> RepteTALIBAN? A
T TALIBAN?
NOI TRUS OE
MIT
R EQPP
MORE COMPETE IN TERM
CONDUCTI WARYES, MA'AM.
>>ep THANKOU
F MOTHAT
HAS BEENNT T NUMBER S THAT L
LAST 20?
>>NOORCAE WA
THTION.
TLY HAVING  FROM NNS IG
PITHD NONET.USTRATIONN HAS  UNID
TH
SUPPORT IT AND REMEMBE
ENANISTAN.
I WAS ASWHE DLY
ESPE OUTTWO RE
UNIT SHARRITOR ACCOMISD BOTHF T
OD
WHY WE SHOULHAVE G N.
ATOVE
THAT'S WHY IIS  RHTAND, QUITE
THYO OVERDUE. orter:>> Reporter:
YOUR OWN ILI
ABWHAT WILL HA  TRUE. ter:IFY W
OT DID
REACAT CCL RS TH
LE
NTSHIP H TO COMEETHER.ARLY HAVP
PLACE.ON KINOF
IT
THEY HAVE PAEYE CAPACITY HFORCE.
THEY HAVE TH
QUHE IT.
O MA WMADE
CLEAR  WARY
AND NOSTEIIN
E O WO TKERE WE HELP THEF
EVERYTNG FROM  NECESSITIES
AN IN TH CONCLUSIOY CANNOT
FEANEVE THE ONLYAY'S
BS IS N
OT THENTE
THE ONLYAY ULTIMATELGOG AND SECH
AS TO HOW THEY ME PEACE. LEL
N
WH HIGHL
UNLIKELY PRESIDENT,
YOU.
T
SCOTT MILLER.ERA
OL CSOS POIL IHE T
STATES D
HIS.T IFRESULT
A CIVIWAR.THAT'STHE
TALIBAN
NUMBER ONE, E  O I- IS GOINGO
ATE THE ENTIRE R
THAVAVE COG TO HAP
PSI THATUDT AF O E UNITED STESL
IESEECS OFHEIR EXPIE WITHDRAWALG
ANYEN WHD
HAPPENED IN VIETNAM  SPEOPLE FE
GA EMBING THROUGH TH
VIETNAMESE ARMY.
THEY'RE NO
IN TERMSTY.
TO
CIRCANCE YOU ARE GOING TE F AN N
S NOT  C
RESIDENTGO TO THE OTHER SIDE.
SEorter:
SERIOUS WAS THE COUPN GOVERNMEN
THIS MISSION FAILING THERE?
THE  IN AFGHANISTAN 'S BEE
CA A UNITY O
GHNAESFGHAN ARTEER TO BE ETWEENB
GORN
COME TFR
SO THEO
THEY GO FROM HERE.
THE JURY IS STL
THE LIKELIHOOD THERE'S GNG OVER
ERTRISKELY.A'ter: MRE
THITESPONS
O WHAT HAT COULD HAPPEN AFTETHE
RNMENT THEY WANTT USO
NO COU EVER BEENDO THAT.
KEEP IN MINDA STEN HISTORY, AS U
NEVER HAS AFANBEEN
>> ReporDENTIF AISOMENT, WT
IN YOUR >> THEREIO
FROM THAF THOU  IT? THE MISSION
P, N YOURARKS, SATISFIEWI
REN NATIIS IT HAPPEN TI,
HAPPENED.OD? IT HAS AL
THE GOTTEN ORAFT AND
FRSALY HAL STAS ONAI SAID,HE OVS
LEAV THAE
WHE PROCESDED MSF BEINABLE TO G.
>>SIDENT, Y
CAN'T THE U.
AF TRANSLATORS TITED
STATES TO AWAIT THEISASOMES OFU.
CORENGING E W. THEE,GUARANTHEY K
WHIS TAKING PLACE T - TO- ANG D
HAVE ACHIEVEMENTEYUT FGH FUTURTH
ACHIEVEMENT.
HEEDH
GOODSO
WHEN I W IANISTA
TIMES, I REMEMR IN A - THEE SCHE
NOT FUNDAMENTALLY UNLIKE SCHOOL
LO
I REMEMBERG - SPEAKING
GROUP OF WOE  THEE 14, 15OLD, T
THIS, OOD
THS A TIERED CLAROH
SINGLE LIGHT HANRO
ID, YOU OW SURE
THISA BIN LADEN, AND THAT
TERRORISO  O
O
LEAVE.
THE YOUNG WOMAN SAID, YOU  L HER
LL, THAT'SSOANY TRAINING THEY  E
IF EVERY WORWAY,
I'M GOING TO TAKE  Reporter: MD.
orter: -- TALIBAUT DRAWL. te MDr
THANNTED TO ASK, WITH E
HOW DOL  TE ONGESTOIIN
THE BENET OF
HINDSIGHT AND AL TIND AMERICTRO?
TNGDET S WAY  NNTST W
PORTITHREOPG HA
ORA, EVS E  TBE,  WERAN.HITHVEE
WENG ITHEV T LOL C
PLL
t,T A ATENEDWO
LIAD TNC AUL INTWAE
.RGNOER
L MBA AHEREMES  WEA
NSSH ICAEY.
OTNOS